the g line this is the square and the  black king steps forward  and uh there you go back with the king  yup the black knight just needs to step  out of the way  um i'm not sure actually wait okay can  you  okay the black knight if it steps out of  the way that does create a threat of  black's king stepping back and attacking  white's bishop um so that would be the  most natural move maybe wesley's just  making sure there are no traps he does  step back with the knight  yeah i mean how is that white bishop  surviving it's  it's there's no way it's doomed this is  fatal now  for napoli actually the white bishop  about to be trapped  does he resign yes he does wow  it's over and actually a smile on janna  pognachi's face  um i don't know what that is about but  he loses that final game and that means  wesley so is the winner of the first  semi-final match  in this one after winning  that final game impressive stuff by  wesley